our chief White House correspondent
major Garrett is with us here in studio
57 good morning good morning so what's
behind the president's calculus here he
needs a win he wants to give a boost to
tax reform we'll get to this in a minute
but those negotiations have gotten
subtly wobbly and a victory in Alabama
might give that some impetus and the
president needs that also he wants to
keep the Trump mystique alive whatever
that mystique is however you value in
American politics he's taken a risk on
Roy Moore he's got a hunch that Roy
Moore's gonna win and he doesn't like to
lose he lost in the primary he doesn't
want two straight losses in a big Trump
state like Alabama and he wants to defy
his daughter defied the other state
Republicans an hour
well Ivanka membership comments that
could be interpreted as hostile to Roy
mores campaign and be out there and if
one more wins say you're with me I'm
with you and I need your vote in the
Senate misread she said a special circle
in hell yes not directly much anymore
but it's in that a pity right next to
him what so Mitch McConnell has a very
different guest Senate leader has a
different position than the president
what does he want well let's just say
there's a huge if around this election
result I don't know how much we can put
into the polls
I think the turnout modeling and every
post Trump election is gonna be brand
new and we don't know what's going to
happen but if for one more wins just to
be cynical for a minute if it's a big
win he's safer if it's a very narrow win
he's much more in jeopardy if he wins he
faces an immediate ethics investigation
that's not my words that's Mitch
McConnell's words and Senator Thune here
on the show last stigma and isolation
all those things are very tough things
to begin to send a career with but he's
a vote from the Republican side he's a
pro Trump vote and Mitch McConnell will
be wary of going up against the Trump
White House if more wins because he will
have the most important political
defender in America the president it'll
be interesting to see what they do major
because they keep saying all along let
the people of Alabama decide let's talk
about the tax bill is this the bill that
President Trump says he wants to have it
done by Christmas a do you think he can
do that and is this a bill that he
promised while he was on the campaign
trail it's not exactly the bill he
promised on the campaign trail and the
most important aspect of this
conversation right now gale is view to
asked Republicans in the White House
last week they would have said 95%
certainty we're going to get this done
I'm told now those projects
are about 65% why the House and Senate
negotiators Republicans all are digging
in their heels for their own bills and
they don't know what the compromise
looks like and they don't know where the
votes are this week coming ahead is
vital to this issue the ability of
Republicans to govern and what remains
of the Trump agenda all right thanks
major thank you